he is the new head coach of usc football
and he is here on the rich eisen show
joining us on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line lincoln riley how are you
coach i'm great rich i'm great thanks
for having me on you bet uh normally i
don't know if you're aware of this you
have broken protocol normally i'm the
one to welcome anybody new to southern
california so
you're a bit you're a bit late i
understand things came together quickly
so uh i i get it but you're gonna have
to give me a rain check on that one yeah
well welcome to southern california a
little bit late but yeah you got it so
are uh have you have you how soon have
you realized that uh that it's the
weather is pretty damn good every day
has that oh that had to be a second i
got off the plane yeah that's uh yeah
it's
hard to believe it's like being on a
vacation never having to go home yeah
you know i i when i first moved out here
from bristol connecticut all those many
many moons ago and i i spent my first
three months in a tv studio pretty much
every day and i kept lamenting to myself
i'm in i'm indoors all day and it's so
beautiful outside and then i realized
that's the way it is pretty much every
day and it kind of i finally found my
groove took me a while you know i love
it and i love it i'll be doing the same
well i mean are are you pretty much
already hitting the recruiting trail
though how much time have you spent in
southern california you're already yeah
not much last week we were we were we
were all over the country last week
we'll be we'll be here a little bit more
this week which will be good and busy
time with our players getting ready to
wrap up the semester and finals and and
then obviously working to hire staff and
and then oh by the way national signing
day coming up uh you know here in about
eight or nine days so it's a
busy time but certainly excited after
that all that happens and the dust
settles to get a chance to to really get
settled in and get the family here and
uh and and get used to living here in
southern cal and so uh did you ever
think you'd live in southern california
ever in your existence in your life
you know i hoped i would i i liked i've
always enjoyed our time out here got to
be out here a few times lots of
recruiting couple vacations out here
i've played in a couple of games out
here so i've always
always loved it and always been somebody
that's that's well kind of new
experiences both for for you know myself
professionally and then most importantly
for my family so that's kind of a you
never know how these things are going to
happen but it's certainly a you know a
part of this this whole situation that
we're very excited about lincoln riley
here on the rich eisen show and and i'm
sure you're aware uh going about your
business that your your
arrival here in southern california
surprised so many people because of the
situation you were in in oklahoma
churning out heisman trophy winners and
teams winning championships and having
the right to play for the ultimate
championship so when when did you
consider yourself first poachable coach
because nobody really outside looking in
thought you were possibly poachable when
did you consider yourself that coach um
you know i really honestly i really
never did i mean i i was
you know very we were very very happy at
oklahoma people there were great to us
like you said we had a really good
situation but this this
opportunity this opportunity came up and
the more we the more we get to learn
more about it um and and can listen to
the vision of the people here and i
think more for us just just kind of
thinking about the possibilities the new
challenges the new excitement um it was
just something that was a little bit
surprisingly but something that just
really
as it became more and more clear
it was something that we wanted to do as
a family and a challenge that we were
ready to take on so anytime you you do
something new i mean there's going to be
you know a lot of excitement nervous
energy i mean just kind of that eager
anticipation but it was at any point
uh as we started to learn about ufc you
could kind of feel the excitement and
you could feel
how bad the people here
want to have this program back to where
it belongs on the national stage and uh
you just i think that the potential
combined with the investment level and
how hungry everybody here is right now
just made it too good to pass it up so
what what about your current situation
do you feel gives you a better chance
than the one that you had
i don't know that i would say better or
compare it was just more it was more
about we felt like this could be great
and part of it is
obviously it has been great before and i
think people recognize the potential of
your location you're coaching at one of
the premier institutions in the country
uh the history of this place how many
people are invested and want this place
to do well the talent base i mean just
it was just a combination of everything
here and you start to think if we can
get there if we can get the culture
right if we can get the locker room
right get the right staff the right
people in here we just felt like that
this could be an unbelievable
opportunity all the way around so yeah i
think it was more of the excitement of
that versus comparing it to any other
situation and then one other aspect
that's been bandied about about your
decision and all this lincoln riley is
the fact that the sec is a lot tougher
than uh the pac-12 and um for you to
have a shot and a seat that might be
more and more difficult to get even with
expansion in the college football
playoff that this isn't i guess an
easier path to that basket and thus it's
something that would also appeal to you
would you agree with that assessment no
i wouldn't i i've never been
i've never been somebody that runs away
from a challenge you know it's not me
and honestly the the easier
probably more in some ways maybe more
comfortable thing to do
would have been to stay at oklahoma like
you said we had so many great things
there so many great people and again i
think oklahoma has a tremendously bright
future no matter who's coaching that
place and uh so
um now this was about
again just a new challenge and there's
so many aspects to making a decision
about this and uh i think you have to i
think you just have to feel like it all
lines up your family for your staff and
their family uh for your future for the
program
kind of where it's at where you think it
can be i just it's so many things are a
factor um and again this those things
all lined up at usc what's your thoughts
on your successor brent venables going
there i'm excited for him man he's been
a good friend for a long time i've
admired him as a coach for a long time
and i know he's been you know i think
being is patiently waited for for the
right opportunity so for him to have a
chance to go back home
he'll do a great job there i got a
chance to visit with him a couple times
before he took the job and and uh no
i'll root for him like crazy and i know
he'll do a tremendous job and what do
you what do you make lincoln riley here
on the rich eisen show the timing of of
your decision one of obviously brian
kelly's as well uh happening back to
back perhaps because the of that early
signing period or that signing period
that you mentioned that you're like oh
yeah oh by the way i've got to start
recruiting now and part of the reason
why you know people are knocking on your
door like usc um when they knocked on
your door is because of that early that
signing period right there december 15th
i keep saying early it just feels early
would you be would you be up for moving
that elsewhere pushing it into january
or something like that i think it's
something we got to consider i mean i
think there's some there's some benefits
to it but also think there's been some
some unintended consequences you know
when you combine that with the transfer
portal i mean those things have
those two things have changed college
football i mean they just have they are
you know and i think everybody knew
that those were two significant changes
when they happened but i don't know that
anybody could have predicted all the
different
um kind of aftershocks that we're seeing
of those two kind of monumental
decisions so um i do think we'll we'll
have to continue to evaluate it because
it does it puts tough timelines on on
coaches it puts tough timelines on
players on universities um you know it's
just not
not not obviously the position that
anybody wants to be in uh when you're
making you know some of these
life-changing decisions so i hope it's
something that we look at there's
obviously some other leagues some
professional leagues that obviously you
know do it a little bit differently and
have more rigid lines and certainly
maybe something we in college football
have to have to really take a strong
look at certainly you know uh you've
already gotten the the star recruit uh
to commit to you here that you had uh
already recruited uh in oklahoma um so
what do you say to folks to that that
are that think that something like that
seems unfair
coach that you get to move and that the
kid then immediately gets to follow you
to the news
i think i think that's the nature of it
i mean every kid has got to make their
own decision and that's uh and again
that's whether that happens
uh whether that happens you know before
a kid goes to college or it happens
after he's been been in college and and
decides to make a move that's that's
that's the nature of the game right
there so we've tried to we've tried to
have a strong um respect for for my
previous employer for for oklahoma um
it's not an easy situation we understand
that but um you know each kid's got to
make his own decision and that's at the
end of the day kids are going to go
where they want to go and uh and so i
think we as coaches um programs we've
got to all understand it and live with
it all right so what's your pitch when
you're going to someone's living room as
the head coach of the university of
southern california what are you really
tell them
honestly it's a fun pitch to make you
know it's uh
you know working again at one of the
premier institutions in the country is
first is the first thing i think the
the opportunity to coach it and and play
at one of the premier football programs
historically that there's ever been and
so much to me all this is about timing
you know it's about the right place
and the right time and i think people
there's a sense of excitement and
anticipation for usc football right now
and a hunger to get it back and you know
there's no no better feeling than being
a part of something like that so that's
honestly you know those those future
trojans are having to make the same
decisions that you know we we just had
to make us and our family so we've been
there we get it we've made our decision
and certainly hopeful that they'll make
theirs well i mean one of the most
embarrassing moments i've ever had as a
broadcaster coach riley was when i did
move from espn to nfl network on nfl
total access and accidentally called it
sportscenter on the air saying this is
sportscenter has has oklahoma slipped
out of your mouth at any point in the
last week we've been close a few times
seven years there
it was pretty ingrained in me but i've
held it together so far i bet i bet so
what what do you say to sooner fans that
are kind of chapped with you and at you
right now what do you say to them right
you know i hope time will heal that i do
i i understand they're i understand
they're disappointed uh that we left i
do um and
you know i have a lot of love for that
place you know we me my family poured
our heart and soul into that place for
for seven years and loved every second
of it you know had a tremendous run of
championships and success on and off the
field and and uh so well we've got we've
got nothing but love you know these
things when you leave a university it's
they're either they to fire you or you
leave on your own accord and neither one
of them are easy and we understand it
but we you know our love for that place
will never go away and uh we certainly
you know hope that as time goes on that
the time we were there will be
remembered fondly and and that everybody
will remember all the great success that
we all had together boss last two for
you coach riley the uh the college
football playoff committee has spoken as
you saw on sunday what do you think
about their decision to go alabama
michigan georgia and cincinnati and in
that order what are your thoughts on
that
you know based on what i thought i
thought that was a a good choice i
thought they probably had one of the
easier jobs this year uh just with the
way that it all played out than maybe
they have in recent years so yeah i
thought all four of those teams had had
they uh had a tremendous year i mean
once you get into it you know having
been in a couple of those once you get
into it i mean everybody's got the same
shot you know so i think they have the i
think they have the right four teams i
think those four teams um
played the best earned it we're the most
consistent and uh should be interesting
to watch okay and the most famous usc
alum that's uh you've spoken to or
reached out to or reached out to you to
this point oh man how do you even uh
i don't know that i'd want to name one
that's there's there's been there's been
a lot i mean you could feel
you can feel the love right now i mean
you certainly can my man colin coward
was as far as usc fans he probably want
me to mention him for sure but there's
been uh now there's he doesn't know
actually no he doesn't link and he
doesn't care he doesn't care if you
mention him
not at all yeah not at all he isn't he
doesn't really mind but okay so no not
at all no it's been great you the people
are they're ready okay coach thanks for
the time greatly appreciate it welcome
to southern california if you need any
uh
you know any uh restaurant
recommendations school recommendations
you know
i'm here for you i can help you out with
you my friend we'll do it take care of
yourself that's lincoln riley head
football coach the university of
southern california right here on the
rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here